let's go next to oh I don't know how
about uh there's a lot of people very
very anxious to get on let's go to David
from Texas David welcome to the program
what's on your mind
David from Texas
baby can you hear me yes I can
okay thanks David man I've been
listening to you for a year and uh
really I've learned a lot and I like to
listen to you and Brian Tyler Cohen and
basically that I was conservative for 60
years and I retired from coaching and
teaching calculus and I decided I better
learn uh all the history and things that
I didn't know as a young person
and so um I was married to a uh I still
am married to a Mexican-American woman
and we adopted
for Mexican-American children so
um I've kind of come out of the bubble
my wife tells me that I was in a bubble
for a long time so that's a super
interesting laugh and do you do you live
in like do you live in a city in Texas
or do you live more rurally Leo I live
west of Dallas about three hours and
about two hours south of Lubbock okay so
it's not it's not it's like a Suburban
environment so to speak
and it's like 12 000 people oh okay
interesting so it's a little and there's
a there's a town about we're close to
Abilene about an hour from Abilene
fascinating and so you just came across
at this stage in your life a total
revision of your political views
definitely
um and my two two of my four children
have really helped me because they are
very
uh liberal and live in bigger cities and
have you know they work in Tech and in
city government and right so they have a
lot of views that have you know helped
me with my new views and my 94 year old
mother and I have been able to spend
time together
in the last few years and achieving very
very conservative
um you know is
still holding out a lot of her
conservative views although I would say
that she's a lot more liberal than she
thinks she is but for example in the
last presidential election as long as
abortion is on top of the the list up
there she was going to be and probably
still always real well conservative but
I as we have our conversations
um we have come to find out I've come to
find out that she's a lot more liberal
than she would think here's just one
example I've got so many things I could
talk to you about but let me just tell
you since my four children are adopted
my mother would always say how can you
be
uh I you know for abortion you know uh
and so whenever people would ask me that
you know how can you be for abortion or
want a woman to have the right to choose
yep
um then you know my answer now is much
like Jamie Lee Curtis I think it was it
said the other night on the Oscars is
that Americans been able to choose how
and how many and when they want to raise
children and adoption is pretty much
exactly tailored in that way we were
able to not only choose when we wanted
to have children how many we wanted we
were able to choose the sex of the of
the children so we have two boys and two
girls
and so that's kind of now my standard
answer is you know it's a choice it
really is you should be able to choose
when you want to have children well said
well said well David's from Texas very
much appreciated and uh thanks for
sharing what is a very interesting story
well thanks a lot Brian all right David
from Texas
appreciate it did he just call me Ryan
that was it I think you might just call
me or Brian did he think he was talking
to Brian Tyler Cohen right there what
just happened I I went over it and now
I'm realizing I think he called me Brian
uh all right let's clip that out we got
to look at that really closely listen to
it like there's a Pruder film and figure
out what happened thank you everybody
who called in we're going to take a
break I'll take calls again very soon